[Music]
towards the night before Christmas and
with his parents and siblings fast
asleep in their beds
little Timmy decided to sneak downstairs
and open his presence early he was
filled of excitement as he began to open
everything but when he finally got to
his own present timmy was left looking
down at a cold hard lump of coal the
room went cold and he could hear the
rattling of chains behind him this year
there would be no visit from Santa for
those who misbehave will only be greeted
by the shadow of st. Nicholas the demon
of Christmas Krampus
[Music]
too many of us Christmas means a time of
joy togetherness and family but if we're
being honest as kids it also meant no
school and a bunch of presence there are
those however unfortunate enough to
experience the dark side of Christmas
those who never got their visit from
Santa misbehave and you will be on
Santa's naughty list but what if that
list was more than just misbehaving
children what if that list was intended
for someone else there's nothing like
tales of a demon who drowns eats and
drags children off to hell to really get
you into the Christmas mood jokes aside
Krampus is one of my personal favorites
and it's also a video that I've always
wanted to come back to and improve upon
stories of Krampus have appeared
throughout Central Europe as far back as
pre-christian Alpine tradition this area
covers a host of countries from Austria
Germany and Switzerland to parts of
France northern Italy the Czech Republic
and Slovakia modern tales depicts him as
the not so friendly companion of st.
Nicholas or Santa Claus who punishes the
poorly behaved while Saint Nicholas
rewards those who have been good however
it may not have always been that way
when discussing Krampus there are two
distinct periods of time that give us
entirely different stories the initial
period of pagan tradition and then the
period after of Christian tradition we
honestly don't know much about his
earliest origin because most pagan
traditions were either forgotten or
absorbed into Christian traditions the
most common belief is that Krampus may
have originated from a horned deity and
we know this extends further than just
pagan beliefs because home gods have
existed in multiple cultures across the
world there is a similarity between
Krampus and the ancient Greek satyr both
being quite rowdy and mischievous but
one is clearly more evil than the other
in old high german the word crampon
meant claw which could refer to a clawed
monster but just like everything else
surrounding his
origins it's all pretty ambiguous the
closest connection we can draw between
Krampus pre and post Christian Alpine
traditions are pagan festivals that took
place during the winter
similar to Yule or winter solstice
during these festivals men would dress
up in masks and animal furs and parade
around villages being a nuisance which
is something they still do today but
we'll get into that a little bit later
so far there's not been much to suggest
that Krampus ever had anything to do
with Christmas or Santa Claus other than
appearing at a similar time in the year
in both Austria and Germany it wasn't
uncommon for individuals to wear a
devilish mask and make a nuisance of
themselves during holidays which honored
christian saints this wasn't done as a
tradition honoring Krampus moreso a
pushback against the church which had
been phasing out these pagan beliefs and
traditions you can however make the
argument that this would be the start of
what we would see in the years that
followed if we go even further back the
closest thing we have to an origin for
Krampus comes from a figure known in
Austria as perked her she was mentioned
very briefly by the Brothers Grimm and
the best way I can describe her is as a
combination of Santa Claus and Krampus
rather than having the concept of good
and evil shown by two separate entities
perks are represented both the reward
and the punishment around midwinter
during what we would refer to as the 12
days of Christmas or the Feast of the
Epiphany
she would visit the homes of children if
they were good then they would find a
silver coin in one of their shoes the
next morning sounds a lot like st.
Nicholas right
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
no because if they were bad she would
slit open their bellies remove their
stomaching guts and fill the cavity with
straw and pebbles before sewing it shut
again this also extended to anyone who
ate anything other than meat fish or
gruel during the day of her festival to
symbolize this duality she appeared as a
beautiful woman dressed in white and
other times as a withered old hag
accompanying her or a group of spirits
known as the Parkton who just like perks
her also appeared in two different forms
the beautiful person who brought with
them good fortune and the ugly person
who had fangs tasks and horsetails
not too different from Krampus himself
the ugly perk tan were used to ward off
spirits and demons in one's home similar
to Halloween but in December this led to
men dressing up as these ugly Parkton
and going from house to house driving
out evil spirits in what was known as
the perked and laugh or the perked and
run the church then seen these
celebrations as a demonstration of
immoral behavior trying to stop these
runs from taking place
but many Austrian villages just refused
to comply whilst others chose to dress
someone up a Saint Nicholas to accompany
them on these runs as somewhat of a
compromise around the 11th century
stories of Saint Nicholas began to gain
popularity and this continued until the
16th century were the forum of Krampus
that we know today really began to
manifest the church still locked in a
battle with the Austrian people were
over the perked and decided to just
outright ban the perked enough not
willing to give up entirely the people
then created a new creature similar to
the perks on an appearance but with a
few key changes this creature would now
serve Saint Nicholas and would be known
as Krampus a hairy horned and herb
demonic figure with sharp fangs long
claws and an even longer tongue at this
point in time he wasn't considered the
only one of his kind
Krampus referred to a race of monsters
that appeared during the Yule period
during this period Christians would
celebrate Saint Nicholas December 6 was
known as Saint Nicholas day much like
modern day Christmas st. Nicholas would
deliver presents to those who had been
good those who were not so good would
get either a lump of coal or a twig to
the church the idea of these Krampus
figures was still a symbol of hedonism
and so they decided to assimilate this
belief into their own exists in winter
ceremonies Krampus was then paired of
Saint Nicholas one symbolized good and
the other evil he would then become
associated with the idea of the
Christian devil he was given chains to
symbolize the binding of the devil by
the church he now carried around birch
sticks that he would use to beat
misbehaving children with on his back he
had a basket or a sack that he would
throw those naughty children in when
dragging them off to hell if you were
extremely poorly behaved you may even be
drowned or eaten the night before Saint
Nicholas Day now became Krampus snapped
meaning Krampus night December 5th was
the day this demon was allowed to roam
the streets and villages it was no
longer st. Nicholas given you a twig or
a lump of coal he was only concerned
with the good children the punishment of
the rest fell to Krampus it was fairly
common for the church to integrate ideas
and traditions from other cultures into
their own when attempting to convert
those from a different faith and it does
make sense just turning up on someone's
doorstep and telling them to stop
believing in what they do because they
go into hell
normally elicits a negative reaction
instead showing them that there is a
common ground in your beliefs is much
more effective in this case it was more
so the Austrian people who adapted their
beliefs into something more palatable to
the church and so the story of st.
Nicholas and Krampus is a good example
of how a heathen belief was integrated
despite the major differences the
tradition of st. Nicholas Day went
through quite a major shift as a result
of this going from Saint Nicholas
Vinu a twig if you were poorly behaved
to being dragged off to hell by this
giant demon goat monster but if you were
lucky maybe you'd just be eaten or
drowned in the lake quite the tonal
shift by the 16th century stories of
Saint Nicholas began to be replaced he
now became Santa Claus deriving from his
Dutch name Sinterklaas or father
Christmas if you live in the UK stories
of Krampus remain largely the same and
December 5th was still considered a
Krampus night in many countries with
Christmas being celebrated on the 25th
it's only natural to then want to move
Krampus night to Christmas Eve for those
outside of the alpine region and that's
why you may see this in various stories
and movies despite these celebrations
and festivals taking place in early
December these celebrations can vary
depending on the region they often
involve wearing a wooden mask dressing
up in fur and attempting to look as
terrifying as possible in some towns
it's more humorous and in others it's
slightly more scary but it's all mostly
done in good fun the most popular of
these traditions is the camp which
laughs or the Krampus Run which is
essentially the same as the park ten
mouths groups of people dress up as
Krampus wear in large bells so they can
be heard as they roam the streets in
packs accompanied by a st. Nicholas what
exactly they do depends on how they're
feeling some just scare children and
passers-by some throw snow at them and
others whip them around the back of the
leg then you have those who visit houses
given presents and in exchange they're
given schnapps and brandy so it's pretty
much just adult trick-or-treating and
it's also a pretty good excuse to walk
around being a massive douche for a day
in parts of Austria twigs will be
painted gold and left around the house
all year round as a reminder for
children to behave in the 1800's Krampus
could be found on greeting cards post
cards and on the wrappers of candy these
depictions were rather odd and often
quite distasteful
they feature Krampus has a more devilish
figure with a
actual undertone and this stems from
those in large cities never really seen
these traditions all they had to go by
was the word of the church who equated
Krampus to the devil in terms of his
story these images do make sense but
it's not hard to imagine why some
wouldn't find them suitable it's also
why over the years they've gone from
frightening to more comical in order to
appeal to a larger audience
what's nice to see is that these
festivals and Krampus runs still take
place today and not just in towns and
cities within Austria and Germany but
all around the world even popping up in
parts of North America there's no doubt
that stories of Krampus and those
predating him have a dark tone to them
but to say that he's just evil doesn't
really tell the whole story before they
were Christianized the Parkton served as
protective spirits and Krampus only
really came to as st. Nicholas's
companion as a way to keep these
traditions alive even then he merely
punishes those who were deemed as
deserving he doesn't commit acts of evil
against the innocent and therefore he
can be seen as representing a necessary
evil for many this whole spectacle was
and still is a time of fun and
expression even today families take
their children to these events and
festivals to them Krampus is more of a
Disney villain than a terrifying demonic
story to me Krampus and Saint Nicholas
represent our very own nature we can be
good and we can be evil but in order for
society to function you need incentive
for the good and you need consequence
for the bad even if that is in the form
of a hairy demonic goat monster if just
like me you can't get enough of Krampus
then why not check out our original
story Krampus night and if you're lucky
episode 2 of Dark Lord may even be out
before the end of the year but I
wouldn't hold your breath unless you're
being drowned by Krampus because in that
case you probably want to hold it as
long as you can as always I've been your
host mythology and fiction explained
wishing you all a very Merry
krampus night
[Music]
you
[Music]